it's time for seen and unseen when we
reveal the stories behind the headlines
and for that we turn to Fox News
contributor Raymond aroyo his new
Christmas CD is out Christmas Mary and
brigh burning up the charts Raymond um
earlier we discussed this political
piece that where they said they suggest
Jonathan Martin that Biden can't govern
or run a campaign like other presidents
shocking report yeah well political also
suggests Laura and you mentioned it
earlier his staff doesn't trust him to
even try now they have good reason for
those concerns today the president
welcomed the Stanley Cup winning Vegas
golden knights though it's not exactly
clear that he knows he's the
president president Harris here to make
sure we do this the right
way president Harris is here to make
sure we do it the right way well the
other President Biden appeared before an
Auto Workers Union last week Laura after
struggling to Dawn a union t-shirt he
then struggled with his in tax thanks
for you had no choice they they had no
choice because of what you did you
helped
everybody and look and I want to thank
you for your commitment to Sol to the
solidarity I also want to recognize Ford
Jim and sanis they negotiate ultimately
in good faith and as result all the
workers will be
rewarded Laura the the president has to
be capable of basic speech or at least
reading a teleprompter particularly if
he's going to run and try to stay in
power for four more years this is just
it's a tragedy what we're seeing no well
it's a plan they have a plan and the
plan is playing out and if I mean do
they don't think president X loves this
he loves the fact that he's walking into
a room and Biden is uh doesn't have the
capacity but Laura the president is in a
a state of near constant bewilderment at
a Veterans Day ceremony over the weekend
he seemed totally lost he's flipping
through the pro program trying to figure
out what to do and even laying a wreath
is an exercise in confusion he puts it
down then he goes back then the soldier
has to tell him go back to your seat sir
please go back to your seat and then he
returns dutifully to his seat which he
miraculously found you know Jonathan
Martin had in his piece and it's very
interesting his two big points when the
GOP goes low quote the Dems go effing
lower okay his other thing is basically
abortion is going to save the Democratic
party if that's all they have to run
when the when people are feeling an
economic pinch over the last four years
I think they're going to be in big
trouble with this kind of performance
well that's it pot porn abortion and an
open border that's their campaign okay
so that's it that's it all right Biden
is not only bewildered Raymond he's um
as a public figure but Soccer Star Megan
rapo she went down in the last game of
her career it was very um it was was it
was actually sad she claims that she
tore her Achilles tendon which is a
horrible injury just ask Aaron Rogers
here's how she described it I mean you
know I'm not a religious person or
anything and if there was a god like
this is proof that there
isn't um so yeah it just it's just up
you guys like it's just six minutes
in my killes I mean what the what a
Charming woman I mean you can't we we
have to beep everything she says she's
so sweet with her with her language uh
maybe the injury though is proof that
there is a God because as you know Laura
he lifts us up and he humbles us maybe
in recovery Megan will have time to
meditate on that uh contrast Rino with
Houston Texans quarterback CJ Stroud who
beat the Bengals this weekend in an
incredible game listen to him all glory
and praise of my Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ u this is a great opportunity um
in a heart game it's a great Bangals
team over there um they they proved it
week in and week out but I mean that's
that's what this league is about those
tough wins U so all glory goes to God
man and um I'm super blessed to be able
on this to be able on this Texas team
and uh play with my
teammates Lauren can you ever remember a
sports person taking full credit for
everything they do their prowess on the
field the luck in the game I've never
seen that until Megan rapino this is
usually call rapo is it rapino have I
been saying it wrong the whole time it's
I don't I have a mental block and saying
it's like you know how Victor Davis
Hansen has a few names he can't I mean
we we kind of tease him about it that's
my that's my achilles Hill I can't say
her last name there's your well don't
pop your Achilles tend in whatever you
do but I've got to get this story there
is a secularization happening across
Society you heard it with rapino now
even Christmas is being secularized
according to Wisconsin right now that's
an organization a wossa city
administrator reminded workers that not
everyone celebrates Christmas so
departments should refrain from using
religious decorations or those solely
associated with Christmas such as red
and green colors when decorating in
public spaces within City buildings she
suggests some neutral inclusive
decorations like snowflakes snow people
or festive lighting Laura this is a this
is quite a doozy I wonder is she
concerned about about those who don't
celebrate dwali or Flag Day or kuanza I
mean I this is only dragged out this
kind of exclusionary stuff when
Christmas rolls around I think they
should try that in New Orleans be taking
Christmas out of everything I don't
think that'll go over too well in new
orle it's a Federal holiday it shouldn't
go down anywhere Laura it's a Federal
holiday and we are free to express
ourselves that's not government
endorsement of religion no it is not
Raymond great to see you as always hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else